he's Sam Darnell the former USC
quarterback what do you drive Sam how's
it going I like to say thanks for having
me on and then yeah you know I Drive a
Jeep Grand Cherokee right now but other
than that when I get out so whatever
city I'm in I don't know exactly what
I'll Drive but so if you go to Cleveland
you may get something a little bit more
winter up four-wheel drives probably an
inline right oh yeah yeah no definitely
probably a trucker of some sorts but you
know who knows I would go in with a used
car if I were you okay yes I mean
whatever you say I'll do absolutely Sam
I've guided you I haven't even steered
you wrong but yeah I go in with a used
car and just saying to everybody hey I'm
here for all business here there's no
flash no I'm here yeah all business now
I'm writing it down right now sure you
are all right here's the other thing
I'm gonna guess all these years playing
quarterback and USC and a high school
star and you watched Peyton Manning be
the spokesperson a celebrity pitch guy
and now you're doing it with Kay
Jewelers so what did you learn who did
you take some tips from whether you're
watching them or you ask them in person
about pitching a product here because
here you are your first big product
pitch your moving product Sam yeah you
know I've learned a lot from those guys
there's actually a lot to live up to
with guys like that and what they're
able to do but yeah I'm here on behalf
of Kay Jewelers I'm actually here so I'm
sitting right next to my mom actually
and it's it's amazing you know the type
of love that she's shown me you know
throughout my whole life I'm actually
sitting here with my dad as well but
Mother's Day I actually got my mom a
nice little necklace from Kay Jewelers
it was really easy all you have to do is
go to Kay calm and or go to any Kay
jewelers store in America it's as easy
as that and really such a nice gift for
Mother's Day and she's gonna look great
with it on on draft day as well so
you're supposed to surprise her with
this Sam you don't how
what I did I know I didn't I did I told
her come on no I surprised her this
morning actually I had it behind me when
I was sitting on the couch with Fox and
Friends and they're like yeah so we hear
you got a little surprise for your mom
and so I you know I took the box out and
gave it to her and she shut up she shed
a tear or two can I talk to your mom
yeah yeah she's right here okay hi hi
it's Dan Patrick how are you I'm great
how nervous are you listen to you all
the time
kind of honored to be talking to you
well that's very sweet
yeah so Thursday will be the second
biggest honor of your life when Sam gets
drafted this is the first one in your
life right I agree
okay I understand that yeah it's pretty
remarkable the whole journey and I can't
wait to see my daughter - she's flying
in from Rhode Island - Nita so the four
of us will be together for a pretty big
day I would say where do you want him to
go where do you want him to go I want
him to go to the team that wants him I
you know I want him to play for somebody
that's willing to believe in him and
choose him and give him that kind of
money on he'll work his tail off you
know no matter where he goes so you
don't care if it's Cleveland you're okay
with Cleveland no I'm totally okay with
Cleveland I'm okay with anything I like
having him in California u.s. but I
guess I gotta get on an airplane yeah
Sam from time to time what is it like
what is it like to watch a game when
your son is playing for you and your
husband oh gosh it's exciting you know
and we've been watching our kids in
sports since they were really little
it's all we've done and so watching him
at USC I think it's helped prepare us
for what's gonna be happening now I'm
just you know it's hard you know like
the whole the frenzy of football is
but the whole you know all the
tailgating and all the people that get
gathered before the four hours before
the game and then you have that to our
game it's a pretty big day but it's it's
a blast and he's doing what he loves and
that's what makes me miss you know happy
are you going to help him pick up his a
suit for Thursday no he had some
professional help really knew what they
were doing no that's okay I'm just a PE
teacher well Chris good luck on Thursday
and it's a big day for the family can I
talk to Sam for just a couple more
minutes there yeah and also this
necklace from Kay Jewelers pretty
awesome nice plug mom they put the
pressure he put the pressure on your
husband okay no no now you put the
pressure on your dad to come up with
something big for Mother's Day I'm
soaking it all and sorry my parents and
the friends around me they you know I've
been going a little tour in New York and
they've been you know sending me
pictures and me on TV shows and
everything so it's been a blast I'm just
I'm seriously just soaking it all in and
learning as much as I can but yeah I
can't wait for Thursday though that's
going to be the time of my life and the
biggest moment in my life thus far so
I'm excited what's been the worst part
of this I really think about that
because it hasn't been bad at all I mean
it's there's just a lot of things that I
have to do I mean a lot of things I mean
not that I'm a crazy kid or anything you
know it's pretty easy for me to just go
out in public and just be Who I am and
not have to worry about anything but I
think just going around and handling my
business on a daily basis and people
stopping me asking for pictures and
because it's crazy once once someone
recognizes me I feel like everyone sort
of understands that you know it's even
if they don't even know who I am the
last for a picture because everyone else
is doing it so it's just once someone
asked it's kind of like a snowball
effect where everyone just kind of asked
for pictures that's really the hardest
part but I don't know if there's really
been a bad part of this whole process
it's all been fun then again just just
really happy to be here and soaking it
all in
do you have a nickname I did in high
school for a little bit but it didn't
really last that long
are you embarrassed by I'm not
embarrassed by I could say so like they
would call me because my hair you know
big red big red dog Clifford so I just
kind of morphed into Clifford but you
know there was nothing that was kind of
my sophomore year of high school all the
seniors would call me that and football
so I had to go through the ropes and
earn my respect there and then they'd
stop calling me that
so no but it was it was a fun time in
high school but I liked Clifford and
that I mean yeah no nicknames other than
that other than like Sammy which isn't
really a nickname it's yeah [ __ ] any of
those so were you in any of were you in
classes with my daughter at school I'm
not sure okay yeah yeah well she was in
communication so what what was your
major okay yeah communication damn it
probably was okay what was your GPA
sadly I finished with a 299 GPA give me
that one extra point but uh Sam they
didn't round it off they didn't round it
off no it was uh yeah Wow with if I
would have stayed in school with that
spring semester I probably would have
been able to bump it up which would have
been nice but you know it is what it is
cease to get get degrees Sam that's our
motto in this building yeah alright well
have fun and you know what makes
hug your parents because you know that's
uh I know you didn't get there on your
own and I know you know that but you
know just judging from how your mom is
treating this and hearing her voice
there it's it's a big moment for a lot
of different people so it's been fun
spending the last couple years with you
Sam and good luck on Thursday night yeah
I appreciate it damn thanks for having
me on all right let's Sam dartle former
USC quarterback and mrs. Dorman Mother's
Day coming up
okay Julie I like how mom got into plug
there well done for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]